[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute but let's do it in a way that
makes the snowflakes heads explode let
me be clear before this podcast begins
we are loud proud and do not give a
[Music]
[__] this is the Tony Michaels podcast
real and raw political and social
commentary the freedom to oppress the
rights of other people is not Liberty
you [__] eating [__] ah the smell of
freedom of speech this is the Tony
Michaels podcast and this is Tony
Michaels hey Tony [__]
[Music]
them ooh the side eye from Tish James
the Attorney General of New
York throwing
lasers through Grandpa poopy pants this
morning in the
courtroom boy it's really going over
like a wet Bart in a white thong so far
this morning in New York for Donald
Jessica Trump apparently the reason why
he's not gonna get a
jury this morning is because Alina Haba
did not check the box that he would want
a jury
trial oh my
god
oh the United States of stupidity that's
what they want him to be the dictator of
this morning and the you know the
contrast the contrast on Trader TV news
networks is that is that fire alarms are
really important I don't know if you've
seen this they're really trying to make
oh my God they're trying to make this
into a Insurrection story Jamal Bowman
accidentally sets off the fire alarm in
a separate building from the capital
that's right a different building it's
not he didn't set off the fire alarm in
the capital it's a different
building and they say that's an
Insurrection and they want him to be
jailed just like the January 6
insurrectionist who tried to overthrow
our
government to install Trump as the
dictator and King of the United States
of
stupidity and boy do I have some clips
from the rallies this weekend to show
you
just how stupid his sheep really truly
are it's incredible it's incredible some
of the stuff that has happened over the
last few days since I left you on Friday
and now you're joining me here on Monday
I am the Tony Michaels this is the Tony
Michaels podcast you should catch it
every single weekday Monday through
Friday noon Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific
what you're gonna want to do is hit that
subscribe button right now here on
YouTube you're not going to want to miss
a single episode of this show and you
can go to the Tony michaels.com you can
find all the links there including
including uh buying me a shot if you
want to buy me a shot of joerger that's
right you can buy me shots of joerger on
the Tony michaels.com just go to the
Tony michaels.com you will find it there
at the very top let me show you that
here here it is and go ahead and
subscribe to the Tony michaels.com I'll
keep you up to date with different
changes that we have also you can find
every single episode today's episode is
right at the top you can buy me a shot
there now here's Sunday's rant if you
want to join the patreon page you can
listen to the rant we had last night you
can also send me a venmo super chat if
you want me to bring your message up on
the screen during the broadcast I'll
keep an eye on those as we go along had
a great conversation this morning with
the in the producers corner it is an
early morning show that we do on uh for
patreon if you want to join the patreon
it's right there you also have to join
the Discord and I'll put that link in
the chat as well you should join the
Discord even if you're not going to join
the producers corner but you should
consider it either way we having great
conversations about project
2025 also having conversations this
morning about the January 6 Insurrection
and it kind of reminds me that the
Republicans are highly concentrated on
fire alarms being Insurrection I I don't
understand why they think this is a good
narrative to spend uh but we're going to
break it down here today I'm going to
show you some footage from inside the
courtroom from inside the
courtroom where Donald
Trump oh boy is losing oh man such a
loss not only that he threatened the
judge and the Attorney General of New
York outside the courtroom um basically
calling this a sham trial a sham
trial and as he does you know
everything's fake news to this guy
so and listen I know a lot of people are
you know grumbling and they're very you
know uneasy about some of the speeches
he gave this weekend where he was
calling for Mark Millie's execution um
he was talking about electric cars only
go 30 miles somehow sharks are going to
get you if you have an electric motor on
your boat there's all kinds of stuff to
go around but the one thing that is
obvious is our government is not shut
down
because of
Democrats folks the reason why our
government is not shut down is because
of Democrats I told you weeks ago that
Kevin McCarthy had two choices he had
two and only two he could shut down the
government or he could work with
Democrats to keep it open and he worked
with Democrats to keep it open
now it is kind of flimsy right I mean 45
days really that's the best that's the
best Kev could do Kevin you're supposed
to be the speaker of the house man
you're supposed to be able to kick this
thing a little further than 45 days I
mean we're going to be in the same
situation we were over the weekend in 45
days you know what I mean like it's not
going to take long to get to 45 days
they don't have that many actual open
days of floor of House of house floor I
mean I think it's probably about about
20 maybe half that 15 or 20 days I'd
have to do the math but it's not very
many days uh to get this done and in the
meantime they're going to pretend like
they're still impeaching Joe Biden I
mean they have to do that they gotta
pretend like they're impeaching Joe
Biden don't they I mean how could they
not pretend to impeach Joe Biden I mean
they got to keep the sheeple happy
because that's what that's about then
the impeachment is only to keep the
sheeple happy and give them an excuse
when they're talking to their family
members come Thanksgiving why they're
still voting for Donald Trump well I'm
still voting for Donald Trump cuz that
Biden he's a corrupt criminal and and
that there's tons of evidence of it too
I mean they just they're just waiting to
show it to they're just waiting to show
us all the good stuff all the good
evidence they're waiting to show
us do you see where this is
going do are you getting a clear picture
of how [__] Trump and the Republicans
are you know I know I know a lot of
people don't like when I say he's going
to get trounced by Biden but folks it it
is appearing more and more that if the
Republicans don't do something quick
fast and in a
hurry and install a new dictator and
king of their party uh they're going to
be in big trouble come November of next
year people in this country are not
going to put up with this
nonsense this
[__] listen I don't know if you if
you watched or noticed the crowd size in
Iowa there's more people that show up to
a high school baseball game than showed
up to his rally in Iowa
folks this is supposed to be their King
their God this is supposed to be the
most popular person on the planet more
people were tuned in to watch the Chiefs
game to watch Taylor Swift walk in then
went to Trump's
rally
listen listen to me when I tell you this
they are [__] they're completely
[__] the guy is sitting in a New York
courtroom
today finding out that the reason why
this [__] idiot doesn't get a jury of
his peers to decide the fate of trump
organization after he committed
fraud on the people of New York because
his dumbass attorney couldn't check a
box think about it think about where
we're at in this timeline these are the
people he are he is trusting and it's
not just his legal
team think about this think about it
clearly it's not just his legal team
where he's putting these nink caboots in
charge it's his campaign this is how dis
this is how dysfunctional the Republican
party is and again the part's dead the
Republican party's dead we're just
dragging around a dead body called the
Republican party around our country just
dragging it around acting like
everything's normal no no really the the
Republican party's fine they're fine
they look dead George yeah well you know
it looks dead I mean it doesn't have a
pulse it hasn't breathed in a while it
looks like you know it's lost a ton of
blood but you know it'll be all right
it'll be okay don't worry about it
please please don't worry about it come
on man and you want me to sit here and
tell you there's a huge threat from the
Republican party that's what you want me
to tell you that's what that's what
makes you feel good is the lie that the
Republican Party somehow has some sort
of functionality in this country they
had to they had to rely on the on hem
Jeff and the Democrats to keep the
government open because Kevin McCarthy
knows one fact and one fact only if he
closes the government he will be blamed
Republicans will be blamed and guess
what'll happen in 2024 the Republicans
will not have the House
Majority they're not going to win the
Senate folks forget it [__] it they're
not going to win the Senate they know
that Mitch McConnell knows that Jesus
Christ he can't even he can't even pause
for a moment to let you know that
they're going to lose the Senate and he
glitches all the
time and you want me to sit here and
tell you a lie that the Republican party
isn't in the
[__] as Jasmine Crockett so
eloquently put it they're in the [__]
[__] they're they're their troops
their soldiers and their party are
turning on each other Jason Smith this
morning I don't know if you know who
Jason Smith is he's one he's just one of
the committee chairs in charge of
pretending that they're impeaching Joe
Joe Biden this morning he is turning on
Matt gats who wants to vacate Kevin
McCarthy's
seat and you're gonna start to have Maga
protecting Kevin McCarthy now from Matt
gats and apparently there's a rumor that
Kevin McCarthy wants to expel Matt
gats remember when I've been telling you
that the wedges we should drive them
deep down deep deep down into the
Republican party this is what I've been
talking
about you think think they're going to
do you think they're going to come up
with a CR the Republicans are going to
come up with the CR that the majority
Republicans will vote for in 45 [__]
days they still think Trump is the
president they think Joe Biden is the
most corrupt person on the planet
folks good [__] luck with that and
the Democrats should take advantage of
this every which way they can I mean
we're not going to have a functional
government we know that we know we're
not going to have a functional
government we're not going to have
functional committees that do the actual
work of the people we're not going to
have a functional
caucus of the majority that's going to
actually do the work of the people
they've refused to we're not going to
have a so so we've lost one half of one
branch of government to
authoritarianism to actually do the
bidding of one [__] in this
country who's got 91 charges in four
different jurisdictions and he's sitting
in a trial in New York today where a
judge is probably going to make him pay
250 to 400
million in Damages because his attorney
couldn't check a box to get a
jury and you want me to sit here and
tell
you that the Republican oh my God
Republicans listen I've got a clip the
show you of Jasmine Crockett showing you
telling you out loud that Democrats have
a deep bench they're ready to [__]
fight and they are fighting and this is
why people are getting excited around
the country about the the Democratic
party because finally finally they're
putting on their [__] boxing
gloves finally they're gonna fight for
democracy they're
gonna strategize and not only that
they're gonna hit hard they're not GNA
hold punches because of decorum [__]
decorum they threw decorum out the
window when they elected this piece of
[__] back in
2016 it's time to fight for our
democracy we can talk about the Corum
once we win okay that's what we need to
do is we need to
win let me tell you something our
opponent is down and out and we should
continue continue and continue and
continue to punch our
opponent politically
speaking it has it has to happen at The
Ballot Box folks we have to engage this
country and let me tell you there's no
more dangerous um
dangerous
tool for fascism in this country than
authoritarianism and there is an
authoritarian leader that is controlling
the House of Representatives and it is
not Kevin McCarthy he's doing his
damnest to commit Mutiny on Trump I
really truly believe that it shows that
he is committing Mutiny on Trump because
Trump wants this this government shut
down he desperately needs this
government shut down for his delusional
thought that if he shuts down the
government then they'll stop Prosecuting
him which is wildly
untrue but he believes a lot of [__]
that's untrue he thinks um electric
motors are going to shock you in the
water apparently sharks will get you uh
electric vehicles only go 30 miles
apparently I don't know why he thinks
they go 30 miles um
but we're gonna watch all this crazy
[__] today all this crazy stuff today um
so you know just hang tight we're going
to
um we're going to um get with the news
I'm going to show you some clips from
over the weekend I'm going to show you
some of this Matt
gats Kevin McCarthy Feud which again we
should be driving wedges down in between
the Republican party this is all good
for us uh in in our democracy to get
them to fight fight fight uh and then
I'm going to show you some images from
inside the courtroom but another another
piece of news is that have you heard of
the crypto guy the crypto dude um what's
his name Sam Sam bankman freed ain't
that his name um he's the guy who's been
indicted on several fraud charges where
he was stealing people's money it's a
Ponzi scheme uh this CTO this crypto bro
really crushed the whole idea that
crypto was the next big thing apparently
Michael Lewis
claims in his
book that Sam bankman
freed was negotiating to pay
trump5 billion doll not to run for
president you heard that right Sam
bankman Fred was trying to
negotiate a deal where he would pay
Donald Trump not to run for president
and apparently the price tag
was5 billion do now that's a lot of
money five billion do is a lot of money
I'm not gonna I'm not gonna lie it is a
lot of money but here's the thing
is I think we could could couldn't we
just come up but we could do a GoFundMe
couldn't we we could do a GoFundMe for5
billion do I think I think we could come
up with that money I think the American
people would um I know I know what
you're thinking you're thinking Tony you
would give Trump five billion dollar not
to run for
president I mean really
honestly you know maybe it's the only
way out of this
thing for him run to president I mean he
has no other choice here at least he
feels like he has no other choice right
I mean he's on the ropes already he's
gonna lose going to lose Trump Tower
he's going to lose some of his golf
courses he's going to lose his ability
really has already lost his ability to
do business in New York uh
but but apparently this is a thing now
what they're reporting is is that and
I'm going to show you the clip in the
reporting is that that they don't
actually know who said five billion but
apparently it was $5 billion was what
the price tag was to get Trump to not
run for president I'm not sure exactly
how or
why um they they actually got that to
that figure but you
know that's how we're going to do it
that's what we're going to say um also
speaking of money the message from the
Attorney General of the state of New
York before the trial this morning was
um very poignant um she says here's the
quote my message is simple no matter how
powerful you are no matter how much
money you think you you
have no one is above the law that is
literally her words her liter this is
the quote my message is simple no matter
how powerful you are no matter how much
money you think you
have no one is above the law so that's
how it started this morning on the on
the courthouse steps with Leticia James
bringing Donald Trump to trial and boy
let me tell you something the the actual
side ey that uh Tish James gives Donald
Trump in this courtroom is just [__]
incredible oh man she knows she's got
him she knows she's got him and she
knows what's about to happen His World
Is Gonna Come crashing down because
that's the other news this morning from
inside the courtroom is apparently they
plan on calling four Witnesses from the
Trump organization Trump himself Eric
Trump which should be interesting Donald
Trump Jr and aanka now you noticed aanka
wasn't actually in the
Judgment they didn't Place judgment
against aanka H I wonder what it could
be but apparently they are going to call
those four Witnesses now rather they
plea the fifth I you know I don't know I
hope they do because in a Civil Trial if
you're if you if you have any kind of
notion to look at some illegal analysis
of these things and keeping track of
this case in New York this civil case
against the Trump organization you know
that you can plead the fifth in like a
criminal triy right you can't sell
incriminate yourself but when you plead
the fifth in a in a Civil Trial I mean
because there's no crime right that
you're trying to you know avoid well it
might be but you're really admitting
guilt almost in a Civil Trial when you
plead the fifth
so oh man oh man it's gonna not go well
for Grandpa this morning in the
courtroom if he's called today so we'll
see we'll see what's gonna we'll keep an
eye on some of that news coming out of
the courtroom as we always do here on
the Tony Michaels podcast again I'm
going to show you the rift in the
Republican party I'm going to show you
some videos from this rally in Iowa and
some of the clips that Grandpa he puked
up on stage Grandpa poopy pants oh my
God here's what he's trying to do with
that you know a lot of people are
talking about these lines that he's
trying like the shark line the electric
motors the the the um what was the other
one what's the other one that he's
trying oh yeah he was talking about Paul
and Nancy really disgusting [__] where
he's getting the crow crowd all riled up
about Nancy Pelosi and Paul Pelosi
getting bludging in the head with a
hammer from one of his [__] Q andon
supporters uh who broke into their home
um you know that's kind of gross he's
talking about the execution of Mark
Millie what were some of the other [__]
he was saying just wild ass [__]
something about sharks and windmills
yeah I'm not I'm not kidding oh no
whales that's what it was whales he's
got a thing with the sea animals all a
sudden he's really he's really going
after the sea animals all of a sudden
but I'm here to tell you the reason why
he's doing this and the reason why it
seems so out of step and it's like why
is he saying this type of [__] this is
weird stuff the reason why he's talking
about the border wall and the Obama
Administration when it's actually the B
Administration this guy's trying out new
material right he's working out new
material it's what he's doing he's had
the same old [__] stump PE speech
for [__] years
he goes to weddings at Mar Lago he
crashes weddings at Mar Lago and
Bedminster to give his stupid little
[__] 20 minutes that he has right
well he can't give the 20 minutes like
he used to and the reason why is because
his attorneys are like you can't say
that well you can't say that that's
gonna yeah they're gonna lock you up for
that [__] so he's trying some new stuff
out right he's trying some new stuff out
and apparently next week or this week or
next week judge chuin is going to rule
on some of this this material that he's
trying out whether he's threatening
Witnesses or not I bet she's going to
have something to say about the Paul
Pelosi Nancy Pelosi thing but we'll see
we'll see and we'll see if he keeps
trying this stuff out I hope he keeps
working out new material you know what I
mean because it really again it's going
over like a wet fart in a white thong
and we're going to keep track of it
right here on the Tony Michaels podcast
so don't forget to subscribe here on
YouTube listen on Apple Spotify and
Google don't forget to download every
single episod episode on your favorite
podcast director you will notice that we
are doing it in part one and part two
for your podcast directories on the
audio version of the podcast you'll
notice there's two parts there's part
one which is the first 30 minutes which
is where we're at right now in the time
slot and we do the rant and then the
second half where we show all the clips
and we break it down for you here on N
Tony Michaels podcast so that will be
part two on the audio version if you're
watching it on video you're here on
YouTube you're on Twitch or you're on
Facebook so make sure to follow us over
there and if you're on Twitch twitch.tv
thony Michaels don't forget to link your
Amazon Prime account to your Twitch
account and give us that one free
subscription that you get with Amazon
Prime for gaming over on Twitch you can
give us that one free subscription that
you get and we get a couple bucks and it
doesn't cost you an extra dime if you're
a Prime member so if you're an Amazon
Prime member and you have linked it got
to go renew it every single month so
don't forget if you've done that before
go resubscribe if you need to know how
to do that just go to the Tony
michaels.com that's Theon michaels.com
just scroll on down it says link Amazon
and twitch link Amazon and twitch it'll
give you the directions on how to link
the two and how to resubscribe every
single month it helps us out there if
you want to get in on a venmo chat send
me a message on venmo make sure you
include your handle in what social media
what where you're watching so I can give
you a credit there for the venmo super
chat or if you just want to buy a shot
around for me around for everybody it's
right there too think about joining the
patreon while you're on the Tony
Michaels podcast check it out we had a
great great hour this morning on the
early show the pre-show I do an early
show on Mondays and Fridays every single
week spent a lot of fun I think this is
the third week that we've done the
pre-show what happen it's a little
different than the show we just come in
we chat with other just like a it's kind
of like a room where we chat we call it
the producers Corner over there on
Discord don't forget to join the Discord
as well the link is in the chat but let
me put it in there one more time uh for
you guys if you want to join the Discord
and you should join the Discord rather
you come visit us in the mornings or not
anyways um it's it's great over there on
Discord so go go join that everyone
stick around we'll be right back right
after
this we'll be right back Mark 60 seconds
this is the Tony Michaels
[Music]
podcast are you numb and alone after
storming the capital have you been left
out in the cold after stealing Nancy
pel's mail do you feel exposed to a
government that doesn't share your
patriotic values if any of these
describe you then you're in luck hi I'm
Paul gosar and thanks to my new product
pardon blanket I've got you covered part
in blanket specifically Works to make
you feel safe and cozy after your
involvement on January 6th and if you're
one of the other members of Congress who
also helped with the attempted coup hard
and blanket will protect you too hard
and blanket is made of a sort of soft
fleece and a layer of sheep's wool and
they're 100% made in the USA don't delay
and get your pardon blanket today for
just
$99.99 actual pardon not
guaranteed jumping back into it this is
the Tony Michaels
podcast welcome back to the show it's
part two on the audio version that's
right you get part one and part two on
the audio version now if you download it
on your favorite directory Apple Spotify
Google wherever you download your audio
versions welcome part two and if you're
here live with us welcome back to the
show the Tony Michaels bucket let me
show you a little bit of how well it's
going in New York for for Donald
Trump this is again this is the Attorney
General of New York Tish James here on
the courthous steps let's hear what she
had to say about the trial today and the
other defendants have con committed
persistent and repeated fraud last week
we proved that in our motion for some re
judgment today uh we will prove our
other claims my message is simple no
matter how powerful you are no matter
how much money you think you may have no
one is above the law and it is my
responsibility and my duty and my job to
enforce it the law is both powerful and
fragile and today in court we will prove
our case I thank you all for being here
and again
justice will prevail Yeah Boy doesn't
matter how much money you think you
have oh man just strikes at him right
just [__] punches dude right in the
mouth just Bop you like that [__]
[__] I mean what what else are
you gonna say that that's incredible I
don't know if she just did that off the
cup or she practiced that but that's the
difference between someone who's serious
and someone who's not
it definitely is it definitely is um the
difference because here's someone who
definitely has no [__] clue what
they're doing here here he here's here's
Grandpa before he gets
into this is a continuation of the
single greatest Witch Hunt of all time
we have a rogue judge who rules that
properties are worth a tiny fraction
100 a tiny fraction of what they
actually are
we have a racist attorney general who's
a horror show who ran on the basis that
she was going to get Trump before she
even knew anything about me she used
this to run for governor she failed in
her attempt to run for governor she had
virtually no polling she came back and
she said well now I'll go back to get
Trump again and this is what we have
it's a scam it's a sham she had
virtually no polling does he think she
wasn't in the poll is that what I don't
understand what he's talking about there
do you but he obviously with the whole
racist thing he's trying to get the
white supremacist all riled up against
the black lady like that's literally
what he's he's trying to do yeah I mean
what how else do you want me to say it
like that's that's what he's trying to
do here is get the racist all ready to
fired up to go after her and here's here
is here's more of this and the threat
well let's actually let's play a
different clip here because there's a
different angle of this that I want to
play here there it is right here um
here's here's the end of that when he
threatens the attorney general or
appears to threaten attorney general you
[__] decide we'll go in and see our
Rogue judge and we'll listen to this man
and uh I think most people get it people
are getting it I can tell you the
voter's getting it because every time
they give me a fake indictment I go up
in the polls and that's never happened
before but this is a disgrace and you
got to go after this attorney general
because did he say go after the Attorney
General you should go who is he talking
to you who is you is he talking about
the metor is he talking to his
supporters through the media you
decide but this is a disgrace and you
got to go after this attorney general
because and you should go after this
attorney general hm I wonder who he's
talking to he's turning off everybody
from coming in you know I don't know if
you take a look at the outflow of
business businesses are fleeing New York
no no no no they're not fleeing New York
um the judges are telling them that they
can't do business there when you commit
fraud like you're like you've been doing
their grandpa the judge is telling you
that you can't do business in New York
anymore so they're not you're not really
fleeing New York you're not leaving New
York you see the narrative that he's
trying to spin he's like we don't we
don't actually want to do business in
the state of New York no more that's not
what I want to do I hate New York [__]
New York I'm leaving I'm fleeing no no
you're not fleeing New York you're being
forced to leave you [__] idiot
because of horrible horrible attorney
generals and judges like we
have that's why horrible horrible
horrible yeah because they're holding
you in to account that's and it's not
called fleeing it's called taking your
business license from you because you're
um what oh fraud that's what it is you
know uniquely about this picture if you
see in the background you see the
[__] Sun here Eric
Trump really um you know Aderall faed he
had have taken some Aderall but you see
back here is that fake Melania am I just
a conspiracy theorist here but is that
fake Melania and then who's this guy
right here who's this guy right here
that looks like waltin doesn't it and
then this guy the thumb up front with
the with the fake ass
beard Jason Miller do you know what
Jason Miller is oh my God this cast of
losers you think you think he would have
at least brought some winners with him
along you know what I mean like just to
give a sense that they're winning a
little
bit but he just brings his cast of
losers people who are indicted with him
people who can't get social media
platforms off the ground who continue to
continue to capitulate to Trump his son
who's the dumbest the dumb I mean you
know you you're really stupid when
you're a trump but when you're this guy
and the rest of the trumps look at you
like they're stupid and they even
brought the fake
Melania that's fake Melania isn't it I
don't I mean that's what I think or is
that real Melania it doesn't look like
real Melania back there am I am I off my
rocker here am I am I out of
Step I'm serious I'm looking at this and
I'm thinking that this is [__] fake
Melania right 100% is fake Melania back
here in the background cuz real Melania
wouldn't show up to this no [__] way
would real Melania show up to where
she's going to lose her meal ticket
right or what she thinks is a meal
ticket where is Melania by the way hey
can someone check to see where Melania
is at for me and see if she's if that's
the fake one or the real
one oh my god oh man maa's falling apart
they really are falling apart here's the
images from the courtroom if you want to
see um
it's [__] beautiful look at this look
at alen habit
here look at
her oh my God where's fake Milani is she
in this picture is she in here where is
she I don't see her in that picture
Alina habit it looks like she's either
got a fart or just farted one of the
other and old grandpa looks like he's
sitting inside of a shitty diaper isn't
he oh boy these poor s saxs of [__] oh
boy these poor s sax of [__] here he is
again and here's grandpa in his Civil
Trial where he's going to go bankrupt
they're going to absolutely strip every
single [__] piece of his business
away from him remember when they used to
be like well you know what I like about
him you know what I like about him he's
a really good businessman he oh my God
have you seen that TV show The The
Apprentice this guy's a hell of a bus
and and there's people who wrote books
for him they wrote books and then he put
his [__] name on it he's got to be
one hell of a business person who buddy
he just he's Rich George he's
Rich he's not rich I that's the [__]
point oh man poor poor old Donnie poor
old Donnie here's the uh here's the
picture of the side eye uh from TI James
I'm gonna show you the clip here in a
minute maybe maybe we can get a glimpse
of fake Milani in this one is she back
there
somewhere I don't see her in this one
but you see tis James here just giving
him the [__] [__] side ey with laser
beams right dark dark James
here just [__] just killing him with
the laser beams isn't she let me show
you a video because there wasn't
supposed to be video footage uh from the
courtroom this morning but apparently
there was some cameras in the courtroom
uh and the judge had to allow this I'm
sure but let's let's watch here here's
Fox news's analysis of this and I think
they go to Jonathan Turley of this uh I
have a question about court proceedings
let's start with Jonathan
turle is there any way in which those
cameras could have been allowed in the
courtroom for a moment there without the
express explicit permission of Judge
angeron I would be surprised you know my
understanding was that there was not
going to be
photos Jonathan turley's like ah [__]
you really caught me I don't know I said
last week that there shouldn't be
impeachment and there's no evidence
because of impeachment who knows I have
no idea I love their legal analysis
don't you on Fox News they're like me
like the best legal analysis they got
these days is
me it just is not going the way that the
the viewers would want it to go my
friend it just isn't um here's some more
uh let's
see that's U I'm trying to find the clip
of him there's several you know he gave
a long kind of diet tribe this morning
in front of the cameras when he was
entering the courtroom uh here is here's
H more now that's the one I already
showed God damn it I'm trying to
find oh well [__]
it there's so many clips of this
scumbag saying scumbag things um here's
here's some um
msnbc's take from the court right from
inside the courtroom hey guys this is
the first look inside that courtroom our
NBC camera is the pool camera here they
gave us a chance to shoot so now we I'll
see what's happening inside there as
this trial gets underway there's there's
Tish James giving the side eye James y
right boom right there get it girl get
it get
him get
him oh boy she wouldn't miss this for
the world would she I mean this is what
she ran on that's what Trump said said
this what this is what ti James ran on
so of course she's going to be in that
courtroom of course she's going to make
sure that they slam dunk his ass in the
[__] trash of course she is this is
what she promised New Yorkers she would
do and boy TI James delivers doesn't she
sitting there uh actually not at the
front table that's kind of interesting
no look at that look at that screenshot
this screenshot this and post this all
her social media it almost looks like
she feels sorry for him to some degree
doesn't it
oh
man she feels sorry how roughed up he's
going to be after this trial because
she's not trying the case so she's
sitting behind her attorneys yeah the
Attorney General there Laticia James um
thank you so much and there you see
President Trump uh the former president
I should say next to his attorney is it
isoc an attorney I mean are these people
considered attorneys I mean that's kind
of a low bar these days in this country
isn't it I mean I don't mean to offend
any lawyers out there but [__] it can't
be that hard to be a lawyer can it I
mean how [__] hard can it be to be an
attorney if you have someone like Alina
hampa now here is the moment let me show
you the
moment here's the moment U that the
judge let the attorney let Trump know
that the reason why he doesn't have a a
jury is because this idiot didn't check
a
box so that's the reason why Trump
actually doesn't have a jury now my is
going to blame it on the Deep State and
all this kind of [__] and I wouldn't be
surprised if Alina Abba ends up being
you know part of the deep state by the
end of this that it was some kind of
Grand's conspiracy and she's the one who
[__] made sure that Donald Trump
would go down and dis James kicked him
eyes down or some I don't know what what
what what is there anything past these
people that they wouldn't say or
do that they would turn on alen habba
here because she is an a [__] and they
didn't understand that she's a [__]
here's a here's a better closeup of
Alina Haba when she realizes the reason
why Trump doesn't have a jury trial is
her whoosh that's pretty rough isn't it
that's pretty rough I don't know may
maybe I'm Maybe I'm Wrong maybe she
doesn't give a [__] maybe she's getting
paid I don't know most Trump's attorneys
do not get paid so maybe they will maybe
they won't I have no
idea but we'll see what the outcome of
this of this here's here's another
closeup
view of the same moment where alinaa
Haba realizes and Trump realizes why he
doesn't have a jury for a trial and why
the judge who has already decided that
he committed fraud is gonna decide the
amount oh [__] that's not GNA be good
for trump it just doesn't feel like
that's going to be good for him you know
what else isn't good for
him he has no control over the House of
Representatives it's clear he wants to
have authoritarian control over the
House of Representatives but they're in
disarray they can't decide what they're
going to do uh they don't know who
actual leadership is they don't know if
they should vacate the seat if they
should keep the seat open they're really
they're they're in a tough spot here
with the House of Representatives so
let's go through some of those clips I'm
going to start here with my friend Chris
Webb he put together a montage of these
Republicans in the house and just see
what what you think here if they're in
disarray or not have you spoken to
speaker McCarthy did he reach out to you
what if so what did he say it was one of
those things just sort of a checking my
barometer but I think if you see my
tweets on Tim burett you know what my
barometer is and I'm ticked off the
American public's ticked off I'm here to
work I'm tired of all the slogans and
all the BS talking points you want to
see him
replaced I want to see him lead is what
I want and I'm tired of tired of just
floating something out let's see how
many votes we can get or what if they
came in and said we're going to replace
this with Marxism or what have you and
then hey we got enough votes let's pass
it I wasn't sure it was going to pass
you want to know why because the
Democrats tried to do everything they
can not to let it pass they did were the
ones who voted for this in a larger
number than Republicans to to keep the
continuing resolution aot did you watch
the floor yesterday yes 0 Republicans
voted against it I mean it's it's
telling it's telling that they can't get
their [__] together and it's telling
that they have to go on media tours to
lie and lie and lie and again let me
tell you something representative
birdshit or or rather it's speaker
pretend speaker McCarthy it's Byron
Donalds who couldn't even make it to the
floor to get the vote you're GNA see
that here in a second or Matt gats
trying to vacate the seat of Kevin
McCarthy because he had to work with
Democrats to do I don't know the bare
minimum that the house is required to do
by law and keep the government open
that's literally the bare minimum the
bare minimum of of congress people's job
in this country is to keep the
government
open literally it is the House of
Representatives job to fund the
government that's their [__] main
purpose is to fund the government and
they can't even manage to do the bare
minimum without Democrats it really is
telling hm it really is
telling that the Democrats are the ones
that have to keep the government open
it's almost like back in January when
they had 15 votes to get Kevin McCarthy
to pretend to be speaker back then that
AEM Jeff won every
vote he won every vote up to that point
he just didn't have quite enough votes
to become speaker and to take the chair
ain't it kind of funny that AEM Jeff
here and the Democrats are the ones who
SA Republicans well it really isn't that
funny because they're
functional they can function as a party
they can function as a government they
know how to govern well why did you miss
this vote and not vote everybody knew it
was coming it's a big deal let here's
well let's hear your excuse Byron
Donald's let's hear your excuse oh it's
a great one listen what happened I
Wasing up the elevator in the capital
building to go vote yeah they closed the
vote down because there were members on
the house floor who were changing their
vote from yes to no I was told that
there were Senators on our floor begging
our leadership to close the votes of the
measure would pass because it needed
two3 the leader hey do you believe Byron
Donalds do you believe him this is the
same guy that submitted a a a h 100b
email remember that 100 B text message
from James Biden about the the robbery
and the corruption in AOC totally
torched him and made him into a liar
immediately in the pretend impeachment
hearing
just last week just last week you
believe this [__] Uncle Tom you
believe him oh don't [__] come after
me for calling him what he
is [__] Byron Donalds is a goddamn
Uncle Tom if I've ever [__] seen one
making excuses making excuses about how
he can't vote people stopped him from
voting because he was in an elevator
[__] out of here with this
nonsense and you're gonna and people are
going to believe this guy come onip knew
I was a no if I was a yes they would
have held the vote open for me they
didn't it's that simple and if at this
time next week Kevin McCarthy is still
speaker of the house it will because be
because the Democrats bailed him out and
he can be their speaker not
mine he can be their speaker not
mine poor Matt gats now there's
talk there's talk out
there that Kevin McCarthy is secretly
trying to expel Matt gats
I don't know if that's true or not I
think it's probably just a [__] rumor
right and the reason why it's probably
just a rumor is because Kevin
McCarthy
wants people to believe that he's gonna
get rid of mat
Gat here at Kevin McCarthy Kevin
McCarthy posted this picture he posted
this picture of him signing the 45 day
stop Gap folks this is the reality of it
he is so proud of this stop Gap look at
him
45 day stop
Gap remember how remember how
Republicans preach to us about how Obama
could never get a budget and Democrats
don't do budgets and how they don't know
how to [__] run our government blah
blah blah blah yakety schacky right on
and on and on it goes
about how Democrats can't get a [__]
budget and all this
nonsense here's Kevin McCarthy
pretending to be Speaker of the House
excited so much so that he had a
photographer come in and take a picture
of him signing a 45 day stop
Gap
45 day stop Gap now if you're not Weare
a CR is continuing resolution A
continuing resolution is to continue the
same type of budgeting that is
current to continue the resolution that
we have for the current
funding this stop Gap is a continuing
resolution but
normally normally a continued resolution
would go three four five six
months Kevin McCarthy already made a
deal back in the spring back in the
spring ring when they raised the debt
ceiling and Joe Biden the Democrats
owned Kevin McCarthy on that negotiation
he got so owned that he reneged on that
deal to keep the government
funded so much so that he pissed off his
caucus because he has no control over
him because Donald Trump controls his
caucus Donald Trump is the authoritarian
Donald Trump is the Speaker of the House
Kevin McCarthy just has the office that
he can take little fancy pictures where
he's signs a 45 day stop Gap and he's
proud of it he's proud of 45 days
folks he should be sitting there in
disgust he should be ashamed of himself
that he can only keep the government
open for 45 days and the only way he can
do it is to seek help from
Democrats cuz he can't get a budget
passed in the house and the reason why
is because his caucus want to destroy
our
country they want 30% cuts across the
board part of it in Social Security and
Medicare Medicaid that's right if you're
out there on Social Security Medicare
and Medicaid they're coming after you
they're coming after your [__] money
it's not entitlements it's your [__]
money you earned it all those years
taken out of your [__] paycheck Time
After Time After Time all the tax you
paid to Uncle Sam to receive Social
Security Medicare and Medicaid
gone they want it gone they want to
destroy that they don't want to fund
it so much so that Kevin has to go to
Democrats to negotiate 45 days and he's
proud of it [__] pathetic what a
[__] joke the Republican party
is that that he can't even do the bare
[__] minimum the thing they [__]
about the most a budget a budget
Democrat ever get a budget blah blah
blah blah yakity schacky yakity schacky
no budget no
budget the best they can do is get help
from the Democrats and get
45 [__] days but listen how Matt gats
views Kevin McCarthy here listen to this
this is fantastic there's nothing better
than this folks this is a huge wedge we
should be using politically all right I
want you to listen to what Hakeem
Jeffrey said after the Kevin new boss
let's even Matt gats knows the
truth sometimes a broken clock is right
twice a day Hakeem jeffre is
is Kevin McCarthy's new boss and here's
why in 45 days Hakeem Jeff holds all the
cards all of them Kevin McCarthy has to
have AEM
Jeff to keep the government open he's
gonna have to pun it you think these
[__] Republicans are going to be
able to somehow get a continuing
resolution that will pass the house and
the Senate and get to the president's
desk without destroying Social Security
Medicare Medicaid and the social safety
net in our country you think that's
what's going to happen no the Democrats
are not going to allow that to happen
they've done said it we are not voting
we are not supporting A continuing
resolution or a stop Gap that that
prevents Americans in this country from
getting the pay that they earned their
earned
benefits we're not GNA do it it's not
going to happen I'm not we're not going
to take money away from Americans
because you can't do your [__]
job got them on the ropes and the reason
why AEM Jeff and the Democrats have
Republicans on the ropes is because they
blinked they didn't do their job they
don't know how to do do government they
just don't know they pretend here's
Alise stefanic pretending that it was
the Republicans who did this not the
Democrats list this [__] as we face
this challenge Joe Biden Chuck Schumer
house Democrats showed zero
leadership oh Elise you lying sack of
[__] the only reason why there is a stop
gap for 45 days and we get to do this
all over again in six weeks is because
Democrats did that for
you because you were willing to pass a
clean stop Gap but let's keep going
let's find out how you feel about
yourself you lying sack of [__] House
Republicans will continue to step up to
lead under the leadership of our speaker
this leadership team but most
importantly all the members of the House
Republican conference we get the job
done and deliver on behalf of the
American people
[Laughter]
oh [__] you lying sack of [__] oh man
didn't oh my
God what
a come on man who you trying to fool who
the [__] are you trying to fool here are
you trying to fool us like other people
are trying to full us and this idea that
you're impeaching Joe Biden because we
know that's not happening either
either do you see how this is going to
go do you see where this is going to
go it's going to go south on these son
of a [__] fast quick and in a hurry
um here's another clip now I want to
show you this and the reason why I want
to show you this because this doesn't
usually happen that I get a clip of Jake
Tapper doing the correct thing right the
media is not doing quite the job that
they need to do to push back on these
line of [__] they just need to push back
on them harder every single every single
every single place that we can but
here's Jake Tapper pushing back on Matt
gats and let me show you how much of a
joker he is even though he's gonna bring
um emotion to vacate he's not gonna win
it because he needs Democrats and
Democrats aren't going to get rid of
McCarthy now now that they know McCarthy
is their [__] tool oh my God AEM Jeff
controls Kevin McCarthy now because
because McCarthy needs Jeff has to have
him to keep the government open but
let's let's listen let's listen to the
[__] 90s this country has been
governed by either continuing resolution
or Omnibus vending and you have voted
for continuing resolution in the past
well I'm I'm five years sober voting for
continuing resolutions and I should uh
note that during those years president
Trump was growing the economy but
January marked a difference yeah and you
know what gr theit as I regret growing
the deficits as well but we were growing
the economy and look look okay so there
it is there it is and and it's easy to
do this stuff why the media doesn't do
this all the time I am no idea this is
so easy to just look at them and say
you're a [__] liar you're a [__]
liar you're lying to the American people
right now on my [__] television
screen why are you doing that and and
you're saying you do one thing and
you're actually doing another well we
well Donald Trump was growing the
economy oh so when the economy's growing
it's okay to have it's okay to have
deficits record deficit
actually 8 trillion do worth the
deficits under Trump's four years which
is as much as much as Obama did in four
years so he had double the amount of
debt that Obama had thanks Obama well
let's listen keep going and Jak Tapper
does the right thing here does not let
up you're talking about the national
debt you were growing what did he what
did he add seven trillion dollars eight
trillion dollars to the national debt
Donald by the way I voted against 10
continuing resolutions under Donald
Trump I did not stand with Donald Trump
on all of his spending priorities I
voted voted against it way more than
point is I don't know what this shutdown
did to help the cause what what shutdown
the shutdown that almost happened okay
so there wasn't a shutdown so the the
threat of shutdown that you created we
have to break the fever we have to move
to single subject broke do you know do
you notice that do you notice and and
Jake's gonna call him on here again I'm
giving Jake Tapper credit which I don't
normally do and I wouldn't normally do
because Jake doesn't do this normally
every once in a while every once in a
while they do it but they don't they
don't do it they don't do what he's
doing here now he's doing it because
it's so easy to do to Matt gats because
Matt gats is an easy target right Matt
gats is a total [__] liar he was
doing this huge media circuit to try to
sell the idea that it's good to shut
down the government because that's what
Trump wants Trump wants the government
shut down the Republican house does not
want to shut the house down they want to
keep their seats
folks Donald Trump does not understand
that you can't just tell people that oh
no Democrats shut it down and they'll
believe it that's not how it works when
the government's shut down they blame
the people in power because that is who
shuts the [__] government
down if you can't govern when you're in
power you can't govern when you're in
the minority either it works both ways
so what people will do is they will
punish the majority when they shut down
the government Trump doesn't know that
the House Republicans do Matt gats
doesn't give a [__] because he's a tool
for Trump Beaver no we didn't
unfortunately that's why we have to now
move to vacate because we have to get a
system where the House and Senate will
negotiate over each of these agencies of
government independently and I
understand that in divided government
that means that you have to take into
account the views of Senate Democrats
the views of the White House but what I
want to you understand that because
you're on the floor of the house talking
about what Kevin McCarthy needs to do is
to allow line item vetos by people like
you line item votes against the salaries
of people who are investigating Donald
Trump the salaries of individuals who
are offering sweetheart deals to Hunter
Biden that to me is not the language of
somebody who understands the balance of
power in house and the Senate and how
all legislation actually functions that
is that to me is the language of
somebody who is looking for uh clicks
and likes and fox hits not somebody who
actually is trying to reduce the debt
well I you you might want to check Fox I
haven't been hitting there as much res L
what I can tell you is that the way the
legislative process works as a 12year
lawmaker in the state and federal level
I think he's going to say a 12year old
didn't you think as a 12-year-old
because that is what the media needs to
do is treat them like they're [__]
12y olds that they truly
are he's got one goal and one goal in
mind it's whatever Donald Trump's
telling him on the telephone that's it
period period that's what he is doing
here good keep going you [__] [__]
keep doing it keep drawing those wedges
down in between the Republican Party
they're dysfunctional they're in
disarray but it really it is their on
brand for them not being able to govern
that's the whole the whole reason why we
as the pro-democracy Coalition need to
be paying attention to the [__] that
matters not the [__] polls that the
media want to sell us right [__] that
[__] don't listen to that [__] them
[__] polls that's all [__] lines
that's just to convince you that the
race is close it is not close folks this
race is not close Joe Biden is gonna
trounce Donald Trump it is going to
happen the media is trying to keep your
attention so that you'll keep tuning in
if you think it's a close
race what they don't know is you're
pissed you're pissed that they're trying
to do that to
you that that somehow they think because
they get to [__] they get to give you
the information that they want you to
have and not the real information not
the truth it's all [__] I'm going to
show you it's all [__] I'm gonna
show you every single bit of it's all
[__] about Donald Trump's popularity
and that somehow he's got a voting block
that's excited about him that's
enthusiastic about him and about his
policies and what he's going to do for
the country that is all 100% horeshit
our country is not
divided there is 10 12% of the country
that is absolute [__] delusional and
they think Donald Trump is somehow a
Jesus but they don't know why and they
don't know what he's going to do stick
around don't go anywhere hit subscribe
on the YouTube channel right now if
you're new to the show you're going to
want to not miss a single episode don't
go anywhere and radio like they say
we'll be right back right after these
messages what the [__] is wrong with you
people it's a rhetorical question at
[Music]
best we'll be right back on the Tony
Michaels podcast
[Music]
fellow Patriots what would you do if
there was a trump supporter right in
front of you crying in pain because they
have to live under communist tyranny we
know what you would do you'd reach out
and give that true American a hand now
here's your chance for only $50 a day
you can help us help those true
Americans recover from Biden's socialist
reign of terror the these are those
Trump supporters and this is that moment
send your donation via venmo to the real
president Donald J Trump it's only $50 a
day recurring and it means you'll get
these Trump supporters the critical help
they so desperately need to survive
under this false regime please donate
now because those Trump supporters you
just saw can't wait another moment [__]
them [__] [__] them [__] [__] them [__]
we're back to the Tony Michaels
podcast welcome back to the show thanks
for sticking around through the break
don't forget to subscribe here on
YouTube if you're on Twitch follow us
there it is free to follow us if you
want to subscribe make sure you tie your
Amazon Prime account to your Twitch
account you can go to the Tony
michaels.com you can find directions on
there how to do it that'll make it
commercial free if you want to watch
commercial free on Twitch and it gives
us a couple bucks of Jeff bezos's Amazon
money as well and it doesn't cost you a
single extra dime have some people to
think Peter Gary Anthony natg girl with
the shots the shots of joerger thank you
very much for the rounds of shots that
you given last night and this morning
here on the Tony Michaels podcast you
can buy me Shots you just go to the Tony
michaels.com that's the Tony
michaels.com you can buy me shots of
jger everyone knows here at the show
that I love shots of Jagermeister I've
got a venmo chat I want to put up on the
screen as well uh Bill e boy from
YouTube sent this to me on Friday at the
very end I forgot to put it up he says
here you go you [__]
grifter on Friday I talked about how
every people are calling me grifter
because I'm like oh you Tony's job is to
get them all riled up get them all riled
up and then ask for money like well I
mean this is what I do for a living so I
mean to some degree I have to have some
sort of like some sort of money right I
mean you know I got to I got to live I
got to keep the microphone on and you
are the shareholders of the show you are
the shareholders of the show that is
right you are what keeps this microphone
on I could not keep this microphone
phone on without you meaning when you
come here and listen when you share the
the link to the show when you tie your
Amazon Prime account to your Twitch
account when you buy shots when you
become a patreon member all that matters
but more than anything it's because you
show up here every single weekday so do
not forget do not forget to hit the sub
subscribe button on YouTube you're not
going to want to miss a single episode
of the Tony Michaels podcast and you can
download every single episode on Apple
Spotify and Google in part one and part
two every single weekday in the
afternoon when we're done here on the
Tony Michaels podcast live live live and
again you should watch live you should
definitely watch live thank you bil e
boy thank you Peter Gary Anthony and
natg girl for the shots uh we also had
artai uh bought a shot on Friday and I
have a couple of let's see your birthday
birthdays today uh jayen
jayen happy birthday to you happy
birthday to you so we got um got several
people in the chat today thousands of
people watching live here on the Tony
Michaels podcast I am happy that you
guys are here because I got some more
Clips to show you here is Matt gats
let's stay on this um Republicans in
disarray here's Matts talking about how
he's going to bring a motion to vacate
Kevin McCarthy's seat as Speaker let's
listen so you have been threatening to
top all McCarthy issue a motion to
vacate uh the speakership uh if he
worked with Democrats to fund the
government with a clean CR clean
government spending bill which is
exactly what he did uh on on Friday uh
and Saturday the house gavels back in
tomorrow at noon are you going to make a
motion to vacate speaker McCarthy made
an agreement with house conservatives in
January and since then he has been in
Brazen repeated material breach of that
agreement this agreement that he made
with Democrats uh to really blow past a
lot of the spending guard rails we' set
up is a last draw and then overnight I
learned that Kevin McCarthy had a secret
deal with Democrats on Ukraine so as he
was baiting Republicans to vote for a
continuing resolution without Ukraine
money saying that we were going to jam
the Senate Ukraine he then turns around
and makes a secret deal now I know you
and I probably have different views on
us involvement in Ukraine but however
you think about that question it should
be subject to open review analysis and
not some back room deal so I do vacate
tomorrow I do intend to file a motion to
vacate against speaker McCarthy this
week I think we need to rip off the
Band-Aid I think we need to move on with
new leadership that can be trustworthy
look the one thing everybody has in
common is that nobody trusts Kevin
McCarthy he lied to Biden he lied to
house conservatives he had appropriators
marking to a different number altogether
and the reason we were backed up against
the shutdown politics is not a bug of
the system it's a feature Kevin
McCarthy's goal was to make multiple
contradictory promises to delay
everything back us up against shutdown
politics and at the end of the day blow
past the spending guard realc agre okay
so the ukrain question is not a is not a
question the reason why Matt Matt gats
and people like marger Taylor green and
others have not come to realize exactly
why they're losing on this front by
pumping Putin's propaganda into our
house Representatives is because most of
the Republicans truly do understand even
though they don't act like it they truly
do understand the reason why this is
happening but let me give you a sense of
what uh this morning some of the House
of Representatives especially leadership
this is Jason Smith if I can find this
clip here it's Jason Smith this morning
talking about Matt gats and uh vacating
the seat and why why they don't give a
[__] um about whether he's gonna vacate
the seat and I also have I also have a a
clip from H Ken Buck the representative
Ken buck and I don't know if you know
this but Ken Buck was a big Trumper oh
my God a huge Trumper [__] love Trump
love Trump not so much anymore because
Trump is gonna go to jail and that's
probably why he do like him but here's
Jason Smith this morning on Fox News
talking about Matt gants
and his and his his mission to vacate
the seat Gates is going to be uh is
going to be reaching out to Democrats to
do this H how is he gonna do it if you
don't have 218 votes absolutely that's
the only way he can be successful is if
he has 200 plus Democrats so basically
Gates is going to work with Nancy Pelosi
Hakeem Jeff and the rest of the
Democrats in order to remove the
Republican speaker and let me tell you
if you remove a republican speaker that
then puts the Democrats empowered these
investigations will be done and stalled
that is unacceptable if
that so they're really trying to sell
their pretending peachment right and
they're really trying to figure out a
way not to vacate the seat because Kevin
McCarthy has given them the power to
pretend to impeach Joe
Biden I'm just telling you man I'm
telling you I can't be more excited
where they're at and do you notice do
you notice what Jason Smith says here
Jason Smith says here that Nancy Pelosi
Hakeem jeffre and the Democrats control
the House of
Representatives did you notice that's
the narrative and the reason why is
because that's the truth because they're
the caucus that is together they're the
ones that have the plan they're the ones
that have a strategy
here
it's true it's true let me show you a
clip of Jasmine Crockett speaking about
this this is this is important and then
I'll come back to the kin buuck clip
there's a lot of Clips so I'm going
through a huge list here but give me
give me just a minute I want to show you
this clip of Jasmine Crockett here
explaining what happened in the hearing
the other day of the pretend
impeachment but this is the reason why
it's it's super important that Democrats
got Kevin McCarthy and Matt gan for that
matter and the entire house by the balls
it's because I don't know they're doing
their job listen to representative
crcket here I really feel like the
Democrats on the house oversight
committee this go around y'all really
came to play from you to um Maxwell
Frost to I mean Al what was the strategy
here the strategy was to show that they
are inept and that this was nothing but
another distraction that the Republicans
wanted to to put in front of the
American people so they thought that
maybe if we make Joe Biden look like
he's half as corrupt As Trump then maybe
the people won't care about the fact
that the government is shut down because
that's a bigger issue and unfortunately
again for them they were out guns um we
have a ton of talent our bench is deep
on the Democratic side and so while I
still haven't really figured out why my
clip went viral everyone brought it in
that committee and I just wish if you
got some extra time people need to sit
down and watch all of us because it was
like a master class and what it should
look like to serve in the house and if
we are going to deal with impeachment I
need the Republicans to understand that
we are not going to play with this
Democrats seemingly are constantly
saying we will stand for what is right
and we will stand against what is wrong
and it doesn't matter your part party
affiliation while they're over here
playing political games and at the same
time as I stated there we have people
that are going to go hungry in the
streets work to be done there's work to
be done and that is the point is there's
work to be done and Democrats are going
to roll up their sleeves and do the work
they're not going to give up they're not
going to walk away they're not going to
make [__] excuses because they want
to govern that's the difference that's
the difference when you elect serious
people that want to govern they'll go
govern if you want to elect unserious
Jokers and clowns like the Republicans
like MAA then they're going to go be
Jokers and [__]
clowns that's how it is going to work
even Ken Buck a career
Republican an establishment career
Republican understands this he knows
this he knows they're dysfunctional he
knows the Republican Party are are on
the ropes listen to him no I think that
the um the weaponization of government
committee the impeachment of of the
president are are all distractions that
will um make sure that the base is
excited make sure the Bas is donating
money make sure uh that people don't
focus on the dysfunction that we have
with a speaker who promises uh something
different to a lot of different groups
and and can't
deliver there you go grift grift grift
gri grift the grifters are gonna grift
baby that's what it's all about Ken Buck
knows it and he's saying it out loud out
[__] loud he's saying it loud and
proud yeah it's all about the grift it's
all about the distraction it's all about
keeping the Sheep
distracted because there's one thing
they know if they do not have the Sheep
distracted they will not be able to get
Donald Trump elected let me show you
some hurting of the sheep from Iowa this
weekend speaking of hurting the sheep
and and the distraction because folks
the House Republicans aren't lying to me
and you Donald Trump's not lying to me
and you that's what kin Buck's trying to
say is they're not lying to me and you
they're lying to the Maga
base that's all they have anymore the
all they have is the crazies the loons
the que and honors listen and we want
him to get his Good Financial going
again do what and a good strong military
huh and just some good morals and
patriotism good good morals and
patriotism listen to that again wait a
second let's let's break this down and
we want him to get his Good Financial
going again get his good financials
going again like stealing more of your
money is that what she's talking about I
can't figure out what his financials are
again maybe she's talking about the
economy but she doesn't even know the
[__] word because she's been so
goddamn diluted these are not stupid
people I'm sure they've just been
manipulated by stupidity but listen keep
going let's do it again and good strong
military a good strong military the dude
wants to execute the former joint Chief
you [__] bonehead wants to execute
military members you dumb [__]
what in the [__] is strong about the the
president of United States wanting to
execute members of the military the head
the leaders of the military what is so
strong about that tell me
please and just some good morals and
patriotism oh good morals and patriotism
like I don't know [__] hating our
country and and and cheering and yucking
it up with his crowd when he's talking
about Nancy Pelos being bludgeon in the
head with a hammer her husband being
bludgeoned in the head with a hammer
come on give me a [__] break is that
really that's really the good morals I
think you mean morals but I mean it's a
[__] cult what are you going to do do
here's some more I'm I'm going to show
you a few more from Iowa I can't even
explain yeah you probably crying well
I'm going to start crying now but come
out on stage I get to see him face to
face live it's gonna be the best day of
my life is she gonna have an orgasm I
don't know I'm just wondering is that
what she's talking about here usually
when someone's like oh my God yeah I'm
gonna see that that's you know it's like
Rockstar type [__] you know what I mean
I I I'm not I'm not saying for sure I'm
asking I'm asking the I'm just asking
questions
let's keep going I love that man oh what
he can do for our
country everybody needs to know he is
number one he is number one our oh my
god did you hear all the policy points
that she wants Trump you know he's
number one and and that's he's a he's
he's Fant it's I mean they can't even
come up with the reason why they want
Trump I'm gonna show you a video from
this rally um that I'm that that I'm
referencing here U I'm going to show you
a clip from it I'm going to keep it I'm
not going to play the the [__] sound
but here is here he is this is him
talking at this is at a elementary
school gymnasium it looks like right am
I [__] right or am I wrong look at
this there's more [__] people that
show up at a high school baseball game
folks this is supposed to convince Us in
Iowa that Trump is the most popular
person on the [__] planet there are
more people who's never been to a
[__] football game in their goddamn
life never even [__] bought a ticket
or watched a game on TV that bought
tickets to the game Chief's game on
Sunday just because Taylor Swift was
there than people in this [__] room
you got
it this person is not popular it is all
[__] most of these people are
probably paid to [__] be there in the
first place don't believe me don't
believe me that some of those people are
being paid to be there well let me show
you let me show you a little clip here
of some of his young supporters you know
Jin Z oh man you got them Jin Z
reporters them supporters oh it's a
great political movement you know he's
been quoting over the weekend that he's
up in the polls with Jin Z here here's
some of his his white incel
jinz supporters here listen to what they
like about Trump man doing good guys
from here
yeah yeah time to see the president
absolutely what the pre the who he is
not the president and they're like yeah
yeahuh oh we read it on a Craigslist Dad
they said they were GNA pay us 50 bucks
if we showed up in a red hat it' be
awesome I wore I wore my non- gay beer
shirt here the CER
shirt okay let's see maybe maybe I'm
wrong Maybe I'm Wrong maybe I'm being
maybe I'm being a little bit too
judgment
maybe I'm putting these guys in a
category that they don't really belong
in in the white fragile male in in cells
category Maybe I'm Wrong let's see if
they have any policy points that they
like what are you looking forward to
today oh that's a big question what are
you looking forward to
today baby that's a good question what
that's what the [__] are you talk
they're looking forward to the 50 bucks
that they're going to be pay at the
front door folks that's what they're
looking forward to they got they got
cers they got queer beer money you know
what I'm talking about let's keep going
hey what would you like for the
president to do to change this country
yeah that's that's a great question
that's a great question what would you
like and it's not the president it's the
former president Brian you're [__]
Looney he's not the president he's the
former president but what would you like
the former president to do for your
country try not to say anything racist
into the microphone son but go ahead
get it back to where it needs to be how
about that um yeah I know you guys how
about that Brady that's what his friend
said how about that the reason why they
don't say anything is because they don't
know anything other than we want it to
be
white you can come after me all you want
but if you think these [__]
standing there want that think anything
about Trump other than he's going to
make us Countrywide again then you're
not paying
attention you're not paying attention
and if you
think if you think these stupid
[__] standing here who came
here for the Craigslist money to hold
signs because they're wearing red hats
and they're racist if you think they're
going to go vote you are wildly out of
Step you are not paying attention you do
not know how voting works you do not
know how ballots work and know that this
age of white men do not vote that is one
thing you should know this age of white
men do not
vote statistically speaking I hope to
change that I hope we change that we get
we get people of this age to realize how
important [__] politics is in this
country and they do start voting but
these guys aren't gonna vote they're not
gonna vote come on you think they're
gonna vote you think they're gonna vote
no they're not gonna vote but that's the
Sheep that's the sheep and they'll
believe anything watch watch watch as
Donald Trump has to explain to them why
at the rally why he couldn't build a
wall so when you hear these lunatics
back there say Trump didn't get anything
from Mexico wait a second did he call
the media lunatics you know what's funny
about that is there's not actually
mainstream media in the back filming him
anymore they're not they don't have to
they just let the trader TV news pool
cameras come in and they broadcast from
those pool cameras there's no mream
media back there anymore so he's calling
the trader TV news networks the
lunatics but listen to what he says
about Mexico see if you can catch about
them the wall remember in 2016 when he
told us he was going to build a wall and
who was going to pay for it listen to
him listen to him how he tells the
people in the room and all his
supporters how he [__] lied to him
back there say Trump didn't get anything
from
Mexico well you know there was no legal
mechanism because I said they're going
to help fund this wall but there was no
legal me you how do you go to a country
and say by the way I'm building a wall
hand is a lot of money is he running
against him self in 2016 he's like ah
couldn't pay for the wall there's no
legal mechanism couldn't get the payment
for the
wall what are you serious is this that's
really what you're gonna do is just tell
them you lied to them and they'll be
fine with it because it's a cult folks
it's a cult it's a cult it's a cult he's
even going to try to convince him that
Obama is the current president listen
you built almost 500 miles of world even
the Obama Administration says it in
their stats the the who did he did he
say the Obama administr is that what he
said let's back it up a second surely
that's not what he said surely he's not
that stupid let's well even the Obama
Administration says no no he is that
stupid he is that
stupid now a lot of people are
contributing this to to dementia right
and a lot of people want to say oh he's
losing his [__] mind he doesn't know
this or that folks he literally is
making this [__] up as he goes he's
trying out new lines on stage he's
trying out new material that's what he's
doing he's really working hard to try
out new material and it's not working
that much it's not working that great
and by the way thanks
Obama what the Obama Administration
that's not the weirdest thing he said on
stage though it's not the [__]
weirdest thing he said on stage let me
show you let me show you some weirder
[__] that he said on stage here's here's
him talking about electric vehicles
let's see what he thinks about electric
vehicles let's go now they want to go to
all electric cars that's great you know
if you want to drive for a half hour and
start let's where do I
recharge you want to take a nice long
beautiful drive in the country you have
to make it a nice short drive in the
country um the reason why you'll have
places to recharge is because of
Democrats and because of the
infrastructure bill I don't if you know
that or
not that's part of it the other thing
too is who the [__] believes that
electric car like who believes an
electric car only goes 30 miles what are
you are you [__] kidding me listen he
doesn't actually believe that electric
car goes 30 miles folks he doesn't
believe that [__] maybe he does maybe he
doesn't know it what he's trying to do
is he's trying to lie to his
base if he can get his base to believe
that electric cars only go 30 miles
imagine what he can convince them of
when he loses the election and he's
trying to convince them that it was
stolen from him again if he can get him
to believe that electric vehicle only
goes 30 miles they'll believe anything
absolutely
anything someone says here candy says
he's an idiot no candy they're
idiots and he knows
it that's the that's the stick and he's
trying these lines out to see which ones
land with the crowd so what he's trying
to do is develop his new his new stump
speech because the old one isn't working
that
well H here's another clip from Iowa
let's see if we can uh well that's not
it um my friend my friend Benny Benny
Johnson Benji oh Benji you piece of [__]
he posted this on um social media of
trump signing a a John Deere tractor oh
my god um that [__] John Deere
tractor is going to need a new paint job
if I can find the clip sorry I got so
many today here we are here we are
here's here is Trump signing a John
Deere tractor this should make you just
gross out oh yeah ready
oh yeah
it you think Biden can do that I
don't do you think Biden could do
that Biden could do a handstand and sign
his name on a John Deere tractor but he
wouldn't because Joe Biden knows how
much [__] hard work goes into that
tractor he would never desecrate an
American piece of Machinery like a John
Deere with his [__] stupid ass
signature on it okay all
right but at the same event at the same
event the Press decided ask Trump
questions oh it's beautiful here's
here's here's how you know Donald Trump
is controlling the House of
Representatives here's the evidence I
give youl you support Matt Gates's
efforts to remove McCarthy as Speaker I
don't know anything about those efforts
but uh I like both of them very
[Music]
much ah if you're not aware if you're a
new viewer of the show we all know here
that Donald Trump
projects every single time he talks and
this is all projection is what he's
doing in this clip literally they ask
him about the feud between McCarthy and
gats right and there gats is going to
bring a motion to vacate Kevin McCarthy
and take him out of power right and
Donald Trump's like I don't I have no
idea who's who's Kevin McCarthy who's
Matt gats who are these people that you
speak of give me a [__] break he is
he he just got off the phone with Matt
he probably sent him a couple venmo
payments you know trying to grease the
skids a little bit you know what I mean
that's what they normally do uh with
Matt gats is grease the
skids but he does he has no clue no idea
I what is this House of Representatives
that you speak of I've never heard of
Congress that's something else holy moly
holy moly but let's see how Kevin
McCarthy is responding this morning on
Fox
News H Fox and Friends here to Matt gat
threat to vacate his seat problem and
then when I had to keep government open
he now wants to make a motion to vacate
but what's very concerning to me now is
the reports I've been hearing all week
and now it's being reported in breart
Matt has been going to Democrats and
offering um subpoena power which will
just destroy any Biden inquiry
impeachment inquiry we have if they
would vote along with him because he'd
have to get all the Democrats to vote
with him to be able to remove the
speaker and I just don't think uh that's
good for the house I don't think it's
good for the country um and what my
point is Bring It On Let's get over with
let's get this over and
let so Kevin McCarthy is it just got
done working with Democrats to keep the
government open he he wants to take
credit for it but it was the Democrats
who kept the government open we all know
that but now he's gonna now he's gonna
say that that the the reason why Matt
gance is gonna lose is because he's
working with Democrats you notice the
continue lie here the continue through
line with the lie here do you see it do
you see it it's almost as good as this
[__] lie here this one here this lie
oh this is a great lie watch this this
is from the Iowa Ry Brian Glenn I don't
know if you know this the guy you're
standing in this clip his name's Brian
Glenn he's kind of a disgrace um one of
the reasons why is because he left his
family and he broke up another marriage
uh Marjorie Taylor Green's marriage
marriage the Congress one from Georgia
uh they're they're they're sh they're
SCH slubbing right now he that's right
this guy this guy Brian Glenn likes to
juice the beetle or get his Beetle
Juiced um by marjerie Taylor green now
we know this other person here is
Christina Bob I don't know if you know
who Christina Bob is Christina Bob is
one of the architects of the Cheeto dust
karuku she's also she's also caught up
in the documents case because she's the
one who signed a false affidavit about
the documents at Marl Lago but let's
listen here what Brian Glenn thinks of
liberal women if you're a liberal woman
listen up liberal women tend to be some
of the ugliest women I've ever seen what
what wait back that up that's surely not
what he said he's dating listen he's
dating margorie Taylor green okay I'm
not making this [__] up he is SCH
slubbing Marjorie Taylor green
sorry just the pure thought of it gives
me a little bit of a puke in the back of
my mouth what did he say again about
liberal
women liberal women tend to be some of
the ugliest women I've ever seen wow
holy moly apparently he believes that
margorie Taylor green is liberal now
these people are wildly Off Their
Rockers aren't they they are they're
just backwards as hell he thinks Mar
Taylor green is liberal did you hear
what he
said I I mean that's what I'm assuming
right I'm assuming that let's keep
listening and I'm serious I mean zero
makeup they take no Pride well they want
to be men they take no pride in their in
their in their dress their attire their
makeup their haircut half of them look
like men hairy armpits hairy legs come
on that is not embracing uh what it what
it means to be a woman get your ass
barefoot put in the kitchen or doing
weird ass pull-ups on a bar I mean if he
wants people to act like they're looking
like men I'm I don't know margorie
Taylor green seems like she works out to
try to look like a man doesn't she I
don't know I I have no idea I'm just
saying look I live weights too and I'm
not saying there's nothing wrong with a
little bit of muscle on a woman I mean
it just means that she likes to work out
she likes to lift but you know you can
either you know have it one way or the
other Brian you can't have it way your
girlfriend's an ugly horse face that's
got muscles like a man okay I don't know
what she has you know down there but I
don't give a [__] it's not my problem
but it sounds
like sounds like it's not going well in
your little relationship with the petty
Yeti boy but this is what they're
talking about this is this is the
[__] hard-hitting commentary that
right- Wingers are
doing
this is the [__] that they're hashing
out just like this fire alarm thing holy
[__] did you hear about this oh my god
there was a fire alarm in the Cannon
Building oh my God even Trump trump at
this little John Deere presser listen
listen to this here here's here's Trump
responding to it he thought he was open
and this is the crap and then they let
him out because he's a Democrat radical
left
lunatic they'll let him out they didn't
arrest Jamal Bowman they they questioned
him they looked at the camera and they
realized that he tried to open the door
which used to be an unlocked door the
door that Jamal Bowman went
through in the Cannon Building to go to
a vote used to be unlocked it didn't
have an alarm on it and it had an alarm
on it he opened the door the alarm went
off he thought he could turn the alarm
off on the
wall the capital police did an
investigation and did the investigation
and they said yeah it was inadvertent
that the alarm went off he wasn't
obstructing a proceeding and the reason
why that that narrative fails and the
reason why Trump fails at this and the
Republicans are going to keep failing at
this narrative with this alarm thing and
let them keep going
honestly because the idea that you would
charge Jamal Bowman for inadvertently
opening a door that has an alarm on it
because it used to not have an alarm on
it and it used to be the door that he
would go through to go to a
vote really does speak and they think
that he should be arrested and charged
with the same thing the proud boy
Enrique tario was charged with the same
thing that the oathkeeper the leader of
the oathkeeper steuart rhods seditious
conspiracy to obstruct an official
proceeding because he set inadvertently
set off a fire alarm in a different
building than the capital where they
hold the vote they are claiming that the
alarm went off in one building okay and
that somehow obstruct the vote in the
building that they were actually holding
the vote in
wildly inaccurate it's a [__] lie all
of it but they're trying to spin it
where Jamal Bowman goes to prison you
see that goes to prison like the people
I sent to the capital to obstruct an
official proceeding listen to this and
he should be prosecuted the same exact
way as the j6 people were prosecuted and
they've been treated many of them have
been treated more unfairly than anybody
in the history of country and I don't
know if I should be saying that because
I don't know what these people behind me
say but I'll bet they agree with me
there's maybe I shouldn't be saying that
because the people behind me think I
look stupid when I'm actually trying to
compare Jamal Bowman to the January 6
insurrectionist who I I am saying that I
want Jamal Bowman to be locked away in a
prison forever but I'm saying the same
thing that the January 6 which is not
the same thing it's not even close to
the same thing have been sentenced to
prison and now that's unfair you see the
jumble jargon that they're doing do you
see the dance that they're
doing do you see how it's going to
[__] it's gonna slap them in the face
it already has it already has it's
already started to it's [__] crazy H
some people are pointing
out Jesse James here on Twitch is
pointing out the Traer Tumblr over here
oh my God the grift is always with these
[__] isn't
it the Traer Tumblr get it for just $10
just
$10 get your Trader Tumblr for just
$10 thanks Jesse for the pointing that
speaking speaking of $10 and grifting U
you know we had we we had Billy Boy tell
me I was a grifter earlier with the
statement thank you Billy by the way for
the grift payment I really appreciate it
but here we're gonna I'm gonna give you
one from Brian Brian asked me a question
on Friday and I missed it so Brian I
hope you're watching he said whatat are
the thoughts on judges being approved
now that Senator Feinstein's passing
apparently this morning uh Gavin Newsome
the governor of California has decided
on who he is going to appoint now I'm
not sure exactly when they're going to
swear her in um and I I need to do a
little more looking into who this person
is uh before I speak on them I'm
actually surprised that it's not barbal
Lee if you want to know the honest truth
but it is Gavin newson's pick so we're
going to go with that but um here's
here's the thing is
uh um we got another Griff payment
coming uh coming in hot um from the
unopinionated bystander on YouTube so
prepare for that but let me finish this
statement on on Senator Feinstein's once
this person is sworn in it will move
quicker they're still going to have to
fill the seat and the Republicans are
going to try to block filling that seat
on the Judiciary Committee for Feinstein
but they will get it accomplished it
will be done and there will be another
it will be another FasTrack into getting
Joe Biden's federal judges approved um
and he'll probably get more approved
than Trump would ever dream of and the
reason why is because Joe Biden is
willing to get up in the morning put his
[__] shoes on and work for this
country and make sure that he's done
right by this country so I hope that
answers I hope that answers Brian's
questions from from Friday H we got
another another venmo chat here that I'm
going to show you here on the screen and
give me just one second to get it to get
it going here it takes me a second
because YouTube doesn't like me you know
that's how it goes that's why you got to
do the venmo chats if you want to do
like a if you want to do like a super
chat right you just go to the Tony
michaels.com hit the vinmo Super Chat
button it'll take you to venmo and you
can send me a venmo um and I'll bring it
up on screen here's one take take my
monies you damn leftwing grifter thanks
for the truth Tony unopinionated
bystander from from YouTube thank you
very much uh to unopinionated bystander
on YouTube for the Griff payment I
really appreciate it uh grifting for the
truth here on the Tony Michaels podcast
the rushin ball of the left as it were
did you know that people call me that
people call me the rushin ball of the
left it is what we really need I mean a
lot of people are like oh that's gross
it's not that gross it really isn't than
gross if you think about it in the
context of media if if you think about
it in the context of how we view
politics and why we are in the position
that we're in uh the rushing ball of the
left could be an important important
tool that the left could use it could be
an import important tool that we Ed for
the narrative in this country to push
the correct narrative and to push back
on fascism because russling ball was
talented I'll say that he used his
talent for vile awful things in this
country and by God if we can find a
rushin ball of the left to use talent in
a way to promote democracy to hold
democracy high on the hill that it
belongs
on that the pro-democracy Coalition can
get round that narrative can drum that
narrative every single day Time After
Time After Time and never let up maybe
just maybe maybe just maybe we can make
inroads in this country and convince
these
boneheads that this is a democracy our
constitutional republic is The Shining
Hill a
shining The Shining Monument on the hill
of democracy and we can get back to a
normal state in our democracy and in the
world and if it takes me fine whatever
and if you want to call me the russing
bald theet fine let's do that let's make
an happen because we're in this fight
together so I appreciate it opinionated
by standing for the leftwing grift
payment I appreciate it Brian your
question and I appreciate all the shots
that are coming in from the Tony
Michaels podcast again if you want to
support the show just go to the Tony
Michaels podcast you can do it there
let's see if we have uh some more shots
coming in we do Lorenzo thank you he
bought a round for everyone so everyone
take a shot I know it's I know it's
Monday and it's 1:42 in the afternoon if
you're on the East Coast but why not
it's it's early enough for everyone to
take a round and a shot on
Lorenzo of Jagermeister so thank you
very much everyone you guys are the
shareholders of the show without a doubt
you are the shareholders of the show and
and without you I could not keep this
microphone on and anything you do to
support this show rather it's Go
download the audio version both parts
part one and part two each day rather
it's go joining the Discord and engaging
over there rather it's rather it's
sending in a shot because it's fun to
buy shots for someone
or you want to send in a vinmo shot so I
get your message up on on on the screen
or you guys want to go buy merch at D
Tony michael.com or if you want to join
the patreon and support every month and
join that $20 tier and come visit us in
the mornings on on Monday and Friday
before the show and just talk to us all
that support but watching it and sharing
it every single day is the most
important thing sharing that link liking
it on Facebook following us on Facebook
going in time your Amazon account to the
Twitch account is important but also
follow us on Twitch watch us over there
on Twitch interact with those people
over there on ttch Twitch
twitch over there on
Twitch it's Monday you know what I mean
it is Monday okay let's get back to some
of these clips I still have a ton to
show there's so many Clips today I'm not
gonna run out of them um all right here
is um Joe Biden in a clip now this is
the RNC research team team that posted
this this is [__] wild [__] folks
this is the RNC research team and Biden
is quoted in this said when I left the
Senate I was able to convince STM
Thurman to vote for the the Voting
Rights Act
Right the RNC points out here in this in
this tweet of this clip of Joe Biden
saying it I'm gonna show it to you it's
not a long clip they say Thurman died in
2003 while Biden did didn't leave the
Senate until
2009 the Voting Rights Act was passed in
1965 before Biden was in office holy dog
[__] do you did you know that the the
Republican Party well l'sen here we'll
watch the clip and then I'll tell you
when I left the Senate I was able to
convince strong Thurman to vote for the
Voting Rights Act strong
Thurman when I oh when he left the said
strong Thurman oh my god oh man well the
Voting Rights Act was passed in
1965 but what the
Republicans don't seem to actually know
here is that
act that
act that act has to be I don't know
every five years has to be or not it's
been re reauthorized five times since
1965 they've reauthorized it five times
and the Republicans don't know that they
don't know that Joe Biden has voted
several times to
reauthorize the Voting Rights Act and in
1982 to be exact stom Thurman voted yay
after he had voted nay on the Civil
Rights Act and Joe Biden is saying
before he before he left the Senate
that's one thing that he did is get
strong Thurman
because technically 1982 is still in the
Senate and left yet strong Thurman voted
nay he voted yay on the Civil to
reauthorize the Civil Rights Act my God
it just doesn't you can't [__] stop
the
stupidity Mueller she wrotes points it
out
here in this tweet in this quote tweet
Republicans don't know that the Voting
Rights Act has has been reauthorized
five times since this passage in 1965
embarrassing but the thing is they do
know this
they do know it the Republican party and
the RNC research team knows it they're
not this dumb I promise you I promise
you they know
this they're lying to their sheep folks
they're lying to their sheep this is a
clip that they're trying to circulate
around social media to say that Joe
Biden is a dummy Joe Biden's got
dementia Joe Biden doesn't even know
when he Liv left the Senate that kind of
[__] that's what they're
doing it's
Insanity it's
crazy absolutely [__]
Bonkers that people are willing to just
regurgitate this [__] but they're going
to and they're goingon to keep doing
this dumb stuff they're not going to
stop this
stuff because they're lying to them
that's what the whole Mark Millie thing
was did you guys catch the mark Millie
thing uh Donald Trump is basically
called for his execution because Mark
Millie made a routine phone call that
the the the secretary defense Mark esper
requested him to make to his counterpart
in China When Donald Trump didn't seem
to be conceding and seem to be lying
about the election that he won when he
actually
lost they were concerned about it they
were really [__] concerned China was
really [__] [__] concerned that
something would happen so Mark Millie
The Joint
Chief made a call to his counterpart in
China at the at the behest of the
Secretary of Defense Mark esper at the
time during the Trump
Administration and Donald Trump is
saying that we should execute him for
treason for making a routine phone call
because it makes Trump look dumb it
makes him look dumb but you know what I
found a clip this morning of someone who
you're going to love explain this um and
he does it in a minute and a half here
this is Pete Buddha judge H if you don't
know Pete Buddha judge is the Secretary
of Transportation a lot of people don't
know that I know that sounds crazy but
people who don't pay attention to
politics don't know who Pete Buddha
judge is and don't know what his role in
government is but he's the he's the
Secretary of Transportation now also if
you don't know Pete budajudge is a
veteran that's right he served in the
military but listen to what he has to
say about this whole whole Millie and
Trump calling for his execution look
this is part of a lifelong pattern with
the former president that I would argue
was first displayed when he uh faked a
disability in order to avoid having to
go to Vietnam and allowed I assume some
working class person to go in his place
and has continued ever since um made a
name for himself by uh under you know
basically saying that that uh he did not
respect John McCain because he was a war
hero uh and you know look a lot of this
obviously is to get attention and uh you
hesitate to reward that on the other
hand we we do in fact still have some
boundaries that matter in this country
and one of them is that our regard for
the military and our respect for the
military is nonpartisan it's
non-political and it's Universal and
that is especially important because
that's part of how the military does
their job I knew every time I put on
that uniform every time I went to work
every time I got into a vehicle every
time I I went outside the wire that I
was with men and women who were serving
and supporting each other and responsive
to a chain of command that was not about
politics that did not uh did did not
break down because of our political
indifferences this undermines that it it
threatens that and it threatens it at a
time when we need those institutions
that are still at least somewhat outside
of the chaos that the last
Administration swed and that some
extreme uh House Republicans are selling
as we speak uh we we need what the
military to offer by way of nonpartisan
stability more than ever and I would say
generald mil has been a Class Act in how
he's dealt with it now back to Mark
Millie and what Pete Budaj is saying
here now a lot of people pointing out
Pete budajudge is a road scholar I mean
there's so many things you can say about
Pete budajudge right he's a road scholar
he's he's a veteran um he's been a hell
of a Secretary of Transportation he's
done a a bang-up job of doing that I
don't know if you remember the bridge
that collapsed in Pennsylvania but Pete
Buddha judge the Secretary of
Transportation and the governor Josh
airo the Democrat there uh came together
and fixed that got that bridge open in
like two weeks less than two weeks when
it' take Republicans 40 years to get
that [__] Bridge open the way that
they go I mean [__] they don't even know
how to govern how how would they be able
to build a [__] Bridge Democrats get
[__] done in this country especially
ones who are serious like Pete budajudge
and Josh Josh
Shapiro um but also Mark Millie is a
serious person I don't know if you
rewind far enough if you can remember
but Mark Millie back in December of 2020
when Trump would not concede uh the
electorial college was already done the
states had already certified their votes
those votes were on their way to
Congress Mark Millie gave a resounding
resounding speech and it was a couple
times that he said this but in the
speech he said that you you do not
swear to a person in the military you
not swear to one person one
man I believe it's his words you swear
to a
document a document is the
Constitution um and it is
telling
when um Trump is is calling for his
execution and the reason why in
this they
want they
want the military to swear an oath to a
person not to the Constitution um here
is Mark Millie
uh over the weekend he's the former this
is his retirement he's a joint Chief uh
the chairman of the Joint Chiefs here uh
he's retiring from that position and
here is Mark Millie over the weekend and
he he throws what seems like a very
sharp knife at Donald Trump listen to a
country we don't take an oath to a tribe
we don't take an oath to a religion we
don't take an oath to a king or a queen
or a tyrant or a dictator we don't take
an oath to a wannabe
dictator boom holy [__] you talk about
daggers Mark Milly's pissed he's pissed
that this is how this is how he has to
retire from his country as the chairman
of the Joint
Chiefs that you would disgrace the
country and the Constitution this way
and especially our military we don't
take an oath to an
individual we take an oath to the
Constitution and we take an oath to the
idea is America and we're willing to die
to protect it every Soldier sailor
Airman Marine guardian and Coast
guardman each of us commits our very
life to protect and defend that document
regardless of personal price now if you
have someone in the military that is
active or a
veteran I would advise you if they say
that they're considering voting for
Donald Trump I would advise you to to
show him that clip save it bring it up
show them that clip tell them who it
is tell them why it's important that
they listen to that
clip it is it is [__] vitally
important that we defend the oath to the
Constitution because here's the thing
folks what Donald Trump wants and wanted
in
2020 was for the military to decide an
election that's what the Chinese were
very concerned
about the Chinese were concerned that
the military was going to step in and
make decisions about the election that
may destroy any chance that China had to
be confident that there wouldn't be
conflict with the United
States China's very confident when the
United States has their military outside
the elections and not deciding elections
because the military has zero zero
influence on our elections and that
that's the way it should
remain we should honor we should support
our military we should support our
veterans we should give them what
they've earned in this country but we
what we should not do is act like they
can install our leaders that is not
their
intent that is not that is not why we
have the military the military is for
National
Defense and if we have to defend
ourselves against like Millie said a
dictator a tyrant a king a queen or a
wannabe dictator fine we should do
that the oath says all
enemies
foreign and
domestic so I salute General Mark
Millie by saying this and I want to play
it one more time I want to play it one
more time it's important to a country we
don't don't take an oath to a tribe we
don't take an oath to a religion we
don't take an oath to a king or a queen
or a tyrant or a dictator and we don't
take an oath to a wannabe dictator we
don't take an oath to an
individual we take an oath to the
Constitution and we take an oath to the
idea that is America and we're willing
to die to protect it every Soldier
sailor Airman Marine guardian and Coast
guardman each of us us commits our very
life to protect and defend that document
regardless of personal price and there
you go there you have it play that all
over the place uh to anyone and everyone
who thinks that the military is going to
swing towards Trump they're not they're
not the military believes in that oath
they believe in it and they believe in
our country and they believe in the
Constitution just as you the pro
democracy Coalition does that's why you
come here every single weekday Monday
through Friday noon Eastern 11 Central 9
Pacific to watch the Tony Michaels
podcast hit subscribe on the YouTube
channel here's what I want you to do I
want you to welcome a couple of our new
moderators here Jim Jim Williams is in
the chat thank you Jim for joining us
and theen has joined us as well welcome
those new moderators and tell the
moderators how great they are and how
great of a job they're doing because
they are the best Moder Raiders in the
world for the best audience in the world
I also have a few shout outs again happy
birthday to Jaylen and Diane she's back
Diane's back she's recovering from
surgery but she's back welcome Diane
back from recovering from surgery we
love having you here every single one of
you every single weekday Monday through
Friday noon Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific
on YouTube Twitter and twitch don't
forget if you have an Amazon Prime
account go to twitch.tv/ thony Michels
you can tie your Amazon Amazon Prime
account to your Twitch account and you
get one free subscription with Amazon
gaming and we get that free subscription
if you give it to us the directions are
at Theon michaels.com that's right the
Tony michaels.com let me show you where
to go to find that right now here's
where you go all right here's where it
is you just go to the very top you hit
subscribe at the top so you get all the
notifications for the brand new episodes
every single weekday here's that link at
the very top you can buy me a shot here
here's the vinmo Super Chat here is the
patreon page but here is how you link
Amazon and twitch the directions are
here also don't forget to resubscribe
every single month and also go down to
the Facebook if you still got a Facebook
account follow us on Facebook you can
watch this show on Facebook Facebook
YouTube and twitch are the three places
you watch and you can download on your
favorite directory in part one and part
two now there's two parts to the audio
version of this podcast download on your
favorite directory everywhere every
single weekday in the afternoon I
appreciate every single one of you being
here and all the Griff payments from ASA
to
Brian Lorenzo thanks for the shots Peter
Gary Anthony nir thank you for the shots
artai thank you for the
shots boy it's gonna be a hell of a week
it's gonna be a week of just a news
waterfall so don't don't forget to come
here noon Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific
for two full hours of the Tony Michaels
podcast until tomorrow same time same
place Surfs Up
[__] you've been listening to
the Tony Michaels podcast in your face
commentary of current events in
political news no rules No Boundaries I
think we've made that perfectly clear we
hope you enjoyed the show and we'll be
back soon in the meantime follow Tony on
social media at the Tony M
and until next time raise a fist and
repeat after
me [__] them [__]
[Music]
them Murphy's mebor head ass
speaking
I